today on the anime zone a review of
school days
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's
am i the only one who's noticed that an
anime everything and everyone seems to
be related to a [ __ ] high school if
you're in a slice of life comedy i've
shown an action i showed you a romance
or mega pilot or even if you're bloody
god then you're probably gonna be some
student in some bloody high school in
japan i mean what is it about high
school life that the japanese love so
much is it the stress the insecure girls
the short skirts the homework the drama
the short skirts the friends the one hot
teacher the short skirts the bullies the
nerds hours studying a subject which
you'll never use in the future or the
short [ __ ] skirts heck originality in
anime nowadays has apparently taken an
obligatory cliche premise of slapping
the word high school in the title to the
extent that pretty much the only high
school premise that hasn't been done in
anime is making a gay musical about it
and so we have school days an anime
which in no way resembles my days at
school and can more physically be named
melodrama days or holidays or [ __ ] days
and i'll be honest watching the show
made me really really angry so while
this review could easily degrade and to
me just going on a crazy round to
completely destroy this anime and his
characters i thought this time i would
keep my review integrity and calm and
professional dissect this anime to
inform more you guys about the key
points and
let's go on with this rant but before i
start i should warn you that i would be
sporting almost the entire plot and the
ending so if you don't want to be
spoiled close this video now you have
been warned school days is the hare
management done by the animation company
tnk in 2007 and it's based on an
electronic japanese adult visual novel
hentai games and while school day has
similarities to a typical harry me that
every girl has to do the metro cardboard
cutout tripping over this one guy whose
only ability seems to be being able to
turn every mundane situation into a
perverted mundane situation differs from
your typical harem by giving every girl
common sense of a cow and replacing the
main character with some [ __ ]
character who won gold in the biggest
[ __ ] competition and is apparently
the biggest [ __ ] in the history of
biggest and [ __ ] and [ __ ] turning
this into a less of a cheesy
lighthearted harem into more of a dark
high school drama if you want to give it
that much credit the anime starts off
with a lovely dovey high school love
triangle so typical and boring that i
was just waiting for the episode where
the hot sister shows up and then
everyone goes off to the hot spring to
see who clicks gimpies in that bikini oh
no wait that kind of does happen but
later on the anime strays away from this
generic romantic comedy into a much
darker path which i can only explain in
maths because there are so many
relationships in this that it will be
easier to understand
and cause i'm asian okay let's start guy
a likes girl b darby doesn't know that
guy a likes her girl c notices that guy
a likes girl b and then sets the two of
them up so guy a goes out with girl b
but then we find out the girl c has
feelings for guy a so we have a typical
love triangle but for here on it gets a
bit confusing guy a keeps striking out
with girl b so he asks girl c for a
relationship advice dlc offers her
advice in a form of practice
practice which just ends up with guy a
sleeping with girl c surprise surprise
later on guy a starts liking girl c and
decides to unofficially go out with her
even though he's still dating girl b
girl d whose girl c's best friend tries
to keep guy a faithful to girl c even
though they're not really going out but
then girl f comes along and confesses
that she has feelings for guy a who ends
up sleeping with her as well girl d gets
tired of guy age eating on girl c and
tries one last time to persuade guy a to
be faithful to one girl and decides the
best way to do this is to [ __ ] him guy
ignoring girl f's persuasive methods
then goes on to sleep with girl g and
then also proceeds to have a foursome
with girls h i and j and after all this
what you may ask does garby do after
finding out everything that guy a has
done
absolutely [ __ ] yes if you can't tell
by now the reason why school days is
such a universally hated anime is
because of the characters and the other
reasons why this anime is so infamous is
because genning is very violent and
shocking and also because apparently
there's a really nice [ __ ] bite
somewhere in this series but let's start
off by describing the characters shall
we cortana is a typical cute innocent
air-headed anime girl whose most
noticeable feature being her big bro
she is the girl our main character
initially likes was probably because of
her sweet cute personality and because
he saw her big breath
well we're supposed to feel sorry for
her because she doesn't really do
anything bad and she gets picked on a
lot because of her shy and secure
personality and has bigger brains
but she becomes batshit insane by the
end of the series because of the main
guy i never really got how she could
like him so much considering they only
seem to be properly dating for about
three [ __ ] days oh did i mention that
she has massive big bouncy jiggly
squeezable curvy bra
sekai starts off as a playful outgoing
girl but later on it becomes evident
that she's just a scheming backstabbing
[ __ ] who acts like she's a caring
friend to everyone but always has an
ulterior motive and in the beginning she
seduces the main character to cheat on
katona after she's just set the two of
them up there's also other minor
characters including the supportive
onlooker the childhood friend the lion
[ __ ] and the three [ __ ] but that only
purpose at the end of the day seems to
be adding more girls for the main
character to sleep with and as for
makoto aka our mainly character
[ __ ]
that is all no but seriously though
makoto could probably be one of the most
hateable characters in anime ever and if
he were a real person he would probably
get hung drawn and quartered by all
female anime fans out there before he
could say shinji ikari everything he
does just seems to be there to reiterate
how much of a [ __ ] he is he doesn't
show any respect for the girls and he
doesn't take responsibilities for his
actions showing us that if you [ __ ]
something and completely cook up the
situation then apparently the best thing
to do is just to pack your bags and get
the [ __ ] out there right america i mean
just look at how he reacts when sekai
tells him she feels guilty that he
cheats you on katonahara with her
no [ __ ] sherlock and this gets me to one
aspect i really couldn't understand
about the show what is so attractive
about this guy i mean with most pricks
in real life there is at least one trait
you can see that maybe some girls would
like but makoto is not only a complete
[ __ ] but he's not even that good looking
and his personality is about as
interesting and appealing as some dried
up wallpaper with steve buscemi's face
plastered on it and this apparently
makes him some kind of japanese hugh
hefner by the end of the show i mean
seriously how does he do it is he just
literally going up to random girls and
going six
[Applause]
so then again it seems like the only
other [ __ ] guy in this school is the
comic relief best friend character who
is apparently their attack stupid and
perverted in front of all the girls as
all anime best friends are therefore and
also school days this style as an
electronic japanese adult visual novel
hentai games so it should come to no
surprise that i show that space in the
game about a horny teenage high school
boy trying to have sex with as many one
dimensional woman as possible becomes a
show about a horny teenage high school
boy trying to have sex with the money
fundamental ah so maybe makoto getting
all the girls does make a little bit of
sense a little bit a really small bit of
sense a teeny weeny minuscule bit of
okay actually still makes [ __ ] all sense
as for the infamous ending it was a
bloody and violent conclusion to a
massive build-up of emotions which did
shock and surprise me while also
immensely satisfying me so props to the
series for being able to do that what
happens in the ending you ask well
spoiler
but even though the ending was very well
done i thought the series was trying to
live off the mirrors of the ending alone
because up until that point the
animation was completely average and the
music throughout most of the series was
completely forgettable with only the
songs that played in the ending scenes
leaving any impact to me now after
searching around i've seen many people
say that this anime is a masterpiece and
praises anime for being a realistic
satire of the harem genre to which i say
bollocks calling school days a satire or
breakdown of the harem genre has given
their creators too much credit if the
show had better writers or gave the
character actions a semblance of realism
then maybe i could see this being a good
tragedy story but any chance for this
show to be taken seriously is thrown
away by the constant use of
shots and panty shots and realism gets
tossed out when every character in the
series seems to conveniently get as case
of stupid at the most crucial moments
leading them to make dumb unrealistic
decisions which only serve to create
more drama and build up to the ending it
was quite obvious that the creator's
intentions were less to create a
realistic breakdown of the harem genre
and more to create one massive
[ __ ] of a melodrama which is
exactly what it is a melodrama and for
that we get lesions of fans praising the
show for being a great original
realistic anime why because the main
character is a guy and he likes to have
sex well [ __ ]
overall school days is just a new take
on the harem drum that try to stand out
by the shot factor of the ending alone
if you're a big fan of melee dramatic
soap operas no matter how stupid they
are you may even like this but for
everyone else stay the [ __ ] away all the
actions the characters take are
unrealistic and only serve to create
conflicts and lead to the worst case
scenario finale while the ending is a
very shocking and satisfying conclusion
which does bring the anime up a few
points it isn't enough to forgive the
anger fell while watching the show the
really boring and generic beginning
anacastic characters which are just so
idiots
yeah shut up i give the show a four out
of ten and while i did rant a lot on
this review i did at least come out this
anime learning one important lesson from
our main character makoto here
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
me